by the way turnout super low for our
first orange president and history's
inauguration I noticed this on
inauguration day early in the morning I
even tweeted about it you'll see that I
actually sent out a tweet which I can
put up on the screen for you I said man
the Washington Mall looked half empty
just now for Trump inauguration compared
to 2009 little did I know how much this
would explode up to an including Trump
showing up for one of his first speech
as as president at the CIA and using
that opportunity to allege that news
lied to hide the real inauguration of
1.5 million it turns out that this is
true and his press secretary is building
it all up the truth is very few people
showed up let's take a look first at
Donald Trump speaking to the CIA about
this I made a speech I looked out the
field was it looked like a million
million and a half people they showed a
field where there were practically
nobody standing there and they said
Donald Trump did not draw well I said it
was almost raining the rain should have
scared him away but God looked down and
he said we're not gonna let it rain on
your speech in fact I when I first
started I said oh no first line I hit
got hit by a couple of drops right and I
said off this is this is too bad but
we'll go right through it but the truth
is that it stopped immediately it was
amazing and then it became really
suddenly then I walked off and a million
million and a half people obviously not
true Trump later claimed claiming the
crowd was all the way back to the
Washington Monument that's not true and
Trump is learning to be a Republican
quickly mentioning that God was
influencing the weather there which
which is quite interesting this is part
of why the Marches matter that took
place and I'll talk about those later
because President Donald Orange is
obsessed with his popularity trumpets
all over Facebook and Twitter telling me
Oh David the reason turnout was low is
because Trump supporters actually have
jobs oh yeah cite some sources that
Trump supporters are more likely to be
employed than non Trump supporters
please cite some sources there and it's
funny how I
the problem was Obama's economy had no
job so on the one hand you have the
Trump is saying there weren't that many
people at the inauguration because Trump
is have jobs I thought we didn't have
jobs that's why we voted for Trump
instead of Hillary Clinton because
Trump's gonna create jobs that don't
exist and then on the other side you
have Ono actually media lied and turnout
was in the millions you've got to get
your lying conspiracy theories straight
don't you yeah I don't think anyone
expected this inauguration to be well
attended I mean he has a 37 percent
approval rating yeah lost the popular
vote by three million and plus to add to
all that you're in this liberal bubble
of DC but just let it go don't make an
issue out of it well they did make an
issue out of it Sean Spicer the press
secretary cranked it up actually saying
this was the largest audience ever he
said let's take it up a notch and here's
Sean Spicer giving his first appearance
in front of the press just making stuff
up out of thin air secondly photographs
of the inaugural proceedings were
intentionally framed in a way in one
particular tweet to minimize the
enormous support that had gathered on
the National Mall this was the first
time in our nation's history that floor
coverings have been used to protect the
grass in the mall that had the effect of
highlighting any areas where people were
not standing while in years past the
grass eliminated this visual this was
also the first time that fencing and
magnetometers when is far back on the
wall preventing hundreds of thousands of
people from being able to access them
all as quickly as they had in
inaugurations past inaccurate numbers
involving crowd size were also tweeted
no one had numbers because the National
Park Service which controls the National
Mall does not put any out by the way
this applies to any attempts to try to
count the number of protesters today in
the same fashion right we do know a few
things so let's go through the facts
please we know that from the platform
where the president was sworn in to
fourth Street holds about 250,000 people
from fourth Street to the media tent is
about another 220,000 and from the media
tent to the Washington Monument another
another 250,000 people all of this space
was full when the president took the
oath of office we know that four hundred
and twenty thousand people use the DC
metro public transit yesterday which is
actually compares
to 317,000 that used it for President
Obama's last inaugural this was the
largest audience to ever witness an
inauguration period both in person and
around the globe yeah so obviously not
true the only thing smaller at Trump's
inauguration than the turnout were
Donald Trump's hands we've got a bunch
of pictures here to show you let's just
start and and for the people who are
watching I'll explain to you what's
going on here so to begin with this was
the original picture we saw Obama's
crowd on the Left Trump's crowd on the
right drastically different the Trump
crowd on the right it filled in a little
bit more but but really not that much
more okay that's number one number two
this is the image the Trump campaign is
tweeting out which looks very full but
the reality is this area pictured here
is always full this is the area in front
of the water you'll see that the water
is at the very very top of this picture
this area is always full and it's a
couple hundred thousand people but the
truth is when you actually look bigger
picture at who was there what do we have
next
Pat to show people this is a map of the
different areas you'll see at the top
are the areas that were filled with
people for President Obama's
inauguration and at the bottom the areas
that had people during the Donald Trump
inauguration it's also very interesting
that there are pictures of the entire
motorcade going by empty parade stands
there's more security than there are
people in this part of the stands during
the Trump inauguration I was imagining
Pat past press teams would try to figure
out how to spin this and they'd say well
what if we cite this or what if we sort
of cast doubt in this way and then the
Trump press team it's almost like they
got together in a room and they said
what should we do let's just call it the
most well attended inauguration ever
what could go good what could possibly
go wrong that's the thing don't believe
your lying eyes believe Sean Spicer he
has it right the trend here is that
everything is everyone's fault but
Trump's media lied pictures were tweeted
weather wasn't good
Trump's 37 percent approval on day one
is why turnout was so low today's
episode of the David Pakman show is
sponsored in part by movement watches I
am wearing my new movement watch today
which is also the one pictured over my
shoulder
her movement watches is cool because the
company was started by two broke college
kids which wanted to wear stylish
watches they would go into the big
department stores and see that the
watches they liked cost four hundred
five hundred dollars even more and they
are now offering really stylish watches
that start at just 95 bucks and they
figured out by selling online they can
cut out the intermediaries and all of
that retail markup and really offer the
best possible prices they've sold over
500,000 watches in a hundred and sixty
countries and you can get 50% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going to mV MT watches dot-com / Pakman
I chose this watch because I really like
the clean design I like the color
everybody that sees it says what watch
is that that's really cool and you can
also step up your watch game and get 15%
off free shipping free returns
that's MV MT watches comm / Pakman PA
que MA